the plague of robocalls is getting worse
consumers received more than 18 billion
in 2017 that's a 75% increase from the
year before they're the number one
consumer complaint to the Federal
Communications Commission which receives
more than 200,000 protests a year robo
calls make up roughly 60% of all
complaints to the FCC Anna Warner's here
with the worsening problem and some tips
for consumers and a good morning good
morning well we all get them you wanna
cruise qualified for lower interest
rates persistent ringing from morning
till night robo calls are disrupting the
lives of millions of Americans with
seemingly no end in sight I get about
five or six robo calls per week the area
codes are from all over the country
Carol Berko is one of millions of
Americans plagued by robo calls daily I
have a baby and I'm always concerned it
could be something about the baby those
calls can be more than just a nuisance
one study found roughly 25 million
Americans lost an estimated nine billion
dollars to phone scams last year and
certain parts of the country are bigger
targets than others a report by u mail
found
Atlanta was inundated with the most robo
calls nationwide with a whopping 183
million in June alone
followed by 97 million in Dallas 93
million in Miami and 88 million in New
York so why do those calls seem
impossible to stop
Margo Saunders senior counsel at the
National Consumer Law Center says the
reason is the payoff so many industries
have discovered how inexpensive they are
to make and these callers have
determined that it's much more
profitable to call people relentlessly
than it is to often comply with the law
in the past year the FCC has proposed
over 200 million dollars in fines
against illegal spoofing by
telemarketers and the Commission adopted
new rules allowing phone companies to
block calls that are likely to be
fraudulent FCC Chairman Ajit PI we are
pursuing every possible Avenue
because we understand and we agree that
this consumer complaint is something
that has to be addressed in soon but
Saunders says she'd like to see the FCC
do more such as mandate phone carriers
to implement better technologies for
call authentication systems to better
combat the problem until that happens
Anna what do we do to get fewer these
calls you know the sad thing is is
there's no one fix for this right you
can take certain actions to help with it
for example put yourself on the Do Not
Call list right right but that doesn't
necessarily where the works for legal
businesses but the scammers illegal
scammers they don't care they'll call
you anyway right so you could download a
lot of there's a lot of different apps
out there for example you mail nomorobo
robo killer or some of these different
apps which will help to cut back on the
calls on your phone your phone company
may have technologies that will help you
some caller ID services for example
where they'll tell you on my phone for
example will come up and say potential
scam which doesn't completely fix it
you're thinking what if it's what if
that's not a scam call what if I'm on
that call and one other thing you do get
a call right you don't want to pick up
but if you do pick up accidentally don't
say anything and don't press the key you
know press one to be taken off the list
that's a total scam that we have you
know so much extra work I know is it is
I barely pick up the phone now this is
just gonna keep it on silent right I
mean not really but kind of know you
don't have a perfect solution we don't
we don't maybe one day it's always
always good to get some tips on that
front